I think there's an incredibly disgusting
Concept in the society that says nice
guys finish last I think it's an awful
thing as a matter of fact I really need
to make a hoodie and start rocking it
that says nice guys finish first because
I really believe that because I think
it's what are you judging like cool you
made 83 million dollars in a bank and
you die and nine people show up to your
funeral was like that good I would argue
it's not I think it's understanding
negativity versus cutting it out we're
all humans I mean I'm gonna go to the
Garden tonight and the things I'm gonna
say to Jimmy Butler are going to be
completely inappropriate though I love
Jimmy Butler it represents so much of
what I believe in but for those three
hours I will not be kind it's the
context you know like every human's
gonna gossip a little bit or like talk
to their best friend in the office about
somebody else in the office I think the
question becomes why you know I ask
myself why do I not spend a lot of time
tearing down other people it starts with
because I'm not tearing down myself